[Music]
have you ever heard somebody say I can't
watch black-and-white movie I have a
problem with this not because some of
the most important movies are in black
and white but because black and white
can do just as much if not more than
color the best place to prove this point
is film noir a style of filmmaking that
continues to influence modern
cinematography everywhere including
Breaking Bad but I'm getting ahead of
myself I want to focus on film noir as a
style to make the case for black and
white filmmaking the first question is
what is still more actually don't think
it requires a concrete definition
because it's something you can feel
especially in modern parries I think I
see where this is going
Chicago know the conversation am i that
predictable only one I can tell what
you're gonna do next maybe my favorite
parody of the style is Calvin and Hobbes
a comic strip can perfectly embody the
cinematography of film noir the contrast
of white black the white trail of
cigarette smoke the long shadows and the
dramatic morally ambiguous narrative but
let's unpack that to start let's
consider black and white done wrong
SNL parodied Casablanca recently and
shot in black and white Oh
noir it is wrong they are parroting this
scene notice a difference in the look of
each shot in the SNL sketch the contrast
is extremely low if I take a sample of
the darkest shade in the shot and
compare it to the lightest shade in the
shot you see there isn't much difference
between the two compare that difference
to the difference in Casablanca the
darkest shade on screen is nearly black
while the brightest shade on screen is
nearly white this dynamic range of
shading makes for a more interesting
shot composition and it really showcases
how black and white can make such an
interesting look with higher contrast I
know I'm comparing Casablanca to a
sketch comedy TV show but it does show
how black and white can look boring and
I think a lot of people see black and
white this way let's see the beauty of
black and white in an experiment let's
take a stock photo in color of a stage
picture that's got the film noir style
let's try desaturating it upping the
contrast and adding some shadow now look
at it the background isn't distracting
from the subject the shadows from the
blinds are more pronounced more focus is
placed on her facial features like lips
and eyebrows the simplicity of black and
white means that the eye can observe
more key features in the shot color is
great but sometimes simple is better in
the age of color filmmakers
for that noir feel have two options the
first is mimic noir but in color blast
the screen with bright vibrant colors to
give the same level of contrast and
aesthetic as black and white movies or
do the opposite film in color but make
the coloring so monochromatic that it
almost looks black and white you can see
this in many gritty movies like 7
inbounds black-and-white filming
emphasizes contrast so it can be used
for visual storytelling the classic
blind shot shows a character that is
literally dark and light lighting is
filmed in extremes one side of the
character is brightly lit the other side
is completely black they've got a good
side and a dark side you may not
actively acknowledge these details but
they suddenly remind the viewer through
lighting that the character might have a
dark side or at least it makes the scene
much more threatening black and white
filmmaking gave cinema these techniques
we still see them in color and they work
well but black and white has a much
stronger look because of the opt
contrast this sequence in Breaking Bad
screen film noir if I make this black
and white you could even confuse it as
an old noir flick I'm not saying
breaking dad should have been films in
black and white but what I am saying is
that Breaking Bad gorgeous
cinematography owes itself to the
techniques that shine the strongest in
black and white movies actually Breaking
Bad has SIL noir lightning everywhere
the blinds the good side in the dark
side high contrast and smoking smoke
looks gorgeous in a black and white
movie the movie the big combo shows all
the beauty of black and white in this
shot silhouettes smoke high contrast it
looks fantastic
so if you want to convince somebody that
black and white has merit give them a
movie that shows off what high contrast
and low key lighting can do show them a
film noir strong light strong black
strong picture so let's get the thing
with a black your life you know really
really really black thanks for watching
here it is the key slightly transform
just a bit of a break from the norm
a little on the brakes of a not neat of
all that heart